thank you thank you very much Robert
welcome down to London we are really
here which is important thing to say at
the outset Jaron
really is the father of virtual reality
and reading his new book the dawn of the
new everything it's been a very
interesting journey for me a bit of a VR
virgin if we're honest and Jaron was
slightly upset by that notion in the
green room before today's Halloran sorry
before this as of something of a VR
virgin myself and only seeing this via
my children walking around with weird
masks on it's very interesting to hear
Jaron who is not only a pioneer of VR
but also has maintained a voice against
the mainstream of Silicon Valley or at
least part of the mainstream of Silicon
Valley which makes huge Ahrens such an
interesting thinker and also the notion
that VR is not simply an extension of
web 2.0 and of social media and that
those companies that may wish it were or
will be should maybe think a little bit
harder about what they're actually
trying to produce so down welcome to
London thank you so much for coming
thank you you head up just to explain to
the audience who maybe haven't met you
before or seen you speak before you head
up Microsoft Research Lab for virtual
reality and a mixed reality and also
Jaron will touch on the differences
between those things and how those will
help you be named as times top 100 most
influential and his books of course
things like I'm not a gadget have been
incredibly influential in the debate we
are all having whether it's in the media
in society about the role of Technology
in the life we're going to live
Jan I know you've often spoken of this
but it is absolutely fascinating about
you could we start off with your your
childhood and your young life and your
entry into this this world so early on
before really anyone had had had Reif
thought about where we are tell us a
little bit about your family life and
how that how about developed into an
interest in VR and all those things
that's a small question it is a question
but these are all very small pocus oh
gosh how do I start well I grew up in a
little town in near the border of the
United States and Mexico near El Paso
Texas my parents were both european jews
my mother was a survivor of a
concentration camp and my father had
lost most of his family in pogroms in
ukraine and i think they just wanted to
get as far away from this scary world as
possible so i grew up as a really weird
kid out of place i went to school on the
mexican side so i actually attended a
mexican elementary school he's just take
a bus across everyday before there was
that big beautiful wall and it was a
charming place my mother then died when
i was small in a car accident and I was
very profoundly traumatized and I was um
I felt so lonely I felt like just a kind
of deep black loneliness and part of how
I found my way out of it was with these
fantasies of ways to reach across to
other people's hidden minds that were
hidden inside these funny sacks of skin
these heads you know and I I was
particularly moved by surreal art I used
to stare at Hieronymus Bosch and I
thought you know what an astonishing
thing that somebody can create this
artifact of something that's not real
but indicates something that is real
mentally something internal and I was
just utterly fascinated by that as a
path towards recovering lost connection
you know and how did that lead on John
to a sense of technology could allow you
to bridge it's fascinating you talk
about loneliness but I know she's
getting into almost that surreal world
what happened was when I was about I was
in college early I was kind of a
precocious kid and when I was oh I don't
know a young teenager I ran across some
of the reports of a researcher named
Ivan Sutherland and just has anybody
heard of Ivan Sutherland here okay well
he's somebody should know about he
invented computer graphics he invented
interactivity on a screen so that that
little thing in your pocket is
essentially a descendant of his PhD
thesis which which was in 1962 and so
Ivan in the late 60s had made the first
what we would call today overt reality
headset
he use different terminology but but
similar he said that he was building a
bridge to a virtual world which is a
term that actually came from art
criticism believe it or not from Suzanne
Langer and art theorists from earlier in
the in the 20th century and so I read
this and I was so excited because I
thought wow if you can just make an
arbitrary world that's this thing that's
this thing I've wanted and there wasn't
an internet then so I used to just run
to strangers on the street and show them
this journal article and there's just
like this really awkward
fifteen-year-old kid and I just like
stop you have to look at this we're all
gonna share our dreams through this
computer thing so I just a little while
later it's actually only a few years
later in my early 20s actually started
the first what I called the virtual
reality company and I thought virtual
reality would be the term that made it
social or like consensus reality and if
it was social then people would see each
other they could turn
- fantastic birds and other creatures
and then they would have this shared
experience that might be a new frontier
of connection so that's that's what it
was for me but of course we have to
pretend it actually was this industrial
operation which it also was yeah that
was always the core for me tell me those
early days that you say I started in
this but of course it wasn't like
Silicon Valley looks like it does now
what was Silicon Valley like in those
early years and where you say you
started wow I mean this is as you say an
era when we were still grappling with
the notion of the first Internet and
just simply being able to look at
information that leap into virtual
reality was still a long way off yeah
well when I showed up in Silicon Valley
which was right at the start of the 80s
it was already there it was already
called Silicon Valley Apple and
Microsoft were both 2 or 3 years old
they were known there was already a
sense of excitement a sense of the
future and I fell in with what we called
the hacker crowd the the the kids who
were good with computers who were
creating this new society and I have to
say the feeling was very different back
then there was a kind of a sweetness to
it that I think is lacking now and in
fact there was a disdain for money
people who were seeking money were held
in contempt I mean I remember one of my
first conversations I had run into Steve
Jobs and some people who work for him
and then I was talking to a bunch of
hackers there's a odd jobs you know he
tried to work at Atari on this chip he
didn't get anywhere so he decided to do
stupid money stuff instead and to them
it was this incredible fall from grace
being a successful entrepreneur was like
this lesser thing that somebody who
couldn't hack would do just to be close
to the real stuff the real hacking you
know and so it's a very different it was
it was a different culture it was very
hippie ish which I guess I still retain
it was it was very experimental it was
very optimistic it was very silly it was
very young yeah I mean I'm the way I
ended up starting a company was not with
any vision of oh I'm going to be an
entrepreneur it was more
Oh God it'll I'm afraid you'll get the
wrong impression if I tell you these
stories could you have to get you know
get a balanced impression for meeting
the whole book but when there was one
all-night 24-hour sort of horrible
greasy spoon eatery where we'd all
gather and it had electrical outlets and
so you know how today you go and you
work in a in a in a place with your
laptop well in those days the computers
were huge they were like if you look at
some of these speakers on this array
here the computer monitors we're as big
as two of those together and we'd
actually haul these giant things in and
then take over a whole table just to set
up one computer and then work through
the night and so there was this the guy
who ran this place would be behind his
counter with the spear trying to spear
the routes he would shriek and we
started rooting for the routes and they
got named so they were never caught and
so we were talking about all this fort
reality stuff and I was ready building I
had made a successful video game said
royalties from evading him so all the
money went into building where true
reality prototypes but without any
business or anything it was just this
garage project and so one day one of my
friends said you know if any of us put
half the effort that this guy puts into
spearing the rats we could like build
these companies like why are we just
sitting here and so it was actually this
Raths peering thing that inspired us
yeah - yeah yeah of course I think these
days this fearing of the rats is
trapping you all and behavior
modification loops through social media
so in a sense the the metaphor persists
we didn't get there what but when did
you when did you get it as a sense John
that that was changing that actually it
was the money men or the money makers or
the people who could work out the
business model for the work you were
doing when did that mood that that that
that notion of Silicon Valley start
changing you know I think sometime
around Google sometime around when
Google started up because we up until
that time
we'd never had this feeling of it was
always kind of a generous thing we're
gonna give you these great tools we're
gonna give you these things that you can
use and then Google see this is so
Google was saying no actually we're
gonna keep your data and we're gonna
organize society we know how to improve
and optimize the world I should say I'm
not speaking ill of Google on a personal
level my friends and I sold them a
company a part of me is there they're my
friends actually really like Google but
there was a very strange thing that
happened around the time that Google
started which is uh there was this very
thick very intense absolutely inviolable
feeling in the hacker community that
things should be free free music free
email and if anyone suggested well if
there was even the most miniscule
postage I would discourage spam if there
was even you know maybe we should give
people a way to make a living since some
day they might lose out to our
automations and all that why don't we do
that any notion of that kind was just
viciously shut down people really wanted
this free thing but the problem is that
that project to make this kind of free
service would still be embedded in this
commercial world where people have to
pay their rent and people were making
companies and it was it was a month it
was a capitalist context so by default
the business plans that are left if you
make everything free are pretty indirect
and strange and so you can say
advertising but then here's the thing if
your Google started out placing outs but
if you're constantly measuring somebody
and then changing the feedback they get
you've you crossed this threshold where
you're no longer doing advertising and
now you're in the world of behaviorist
manipulation you're doing direct
behavior modification incrementally and
to call that advertising completely
misses the point but the problem is that
companies like Google were given no
choice that was the option available to
them so I think what was the funding
they offered and the returns they needed
to make and then fact that deep you know
done did you not need to build
businesses that were profit
if you're gonna build a business it has
to be profitable I mean that's the deal
you know that why else would you do it I
mean why would so so the thing is we
were saying yes build profitable
businesses but no don't sell anything it
all has to be free so what you get then
is is behaviorist manipulation I mean we
we meaning the idealistic kind of left
the hippie class of people gave them
little choice so I mean I want I want
that to be clear this is not like some
evil scheme where they came we're gonna
take over the world and manipulate
everybody we you know it was actually
more a very well-intentioned kind of
sweet ideology that just backfired
terribly that's my view of it and you
were very critical then as we moved on
on to the whole notion which is
connected to to this item you've just
made about web 2.0 and the notion of
sharing data and this idea that this was
somehow connecting the world and was a
super good thing and social media you've
talked about digital Maoism well what
was it you meant by that and you've
touched a couple of times already on
this idea that they are modifying our
behavior and that they they are sort of
manipulating what people think they want
so I started writing cautionary essays
around 92 I was the timeline is I built
this the first reality company in the
80s and then I left it in 1992 and
that's where this this memoir cuts off
and then shortly after that I started
writing cautionary essays and if I may
say so I wish they were bad essays I
wish I was wrong I wish I had not been
prescient because unfortunately some of
these things which seemed rather dark
and paranoid have come true almost you
know very closely to what I what I wrote
and I hate that I want to be wrong when
I'm dark you know but the the what the
the notion that concerned me was well
first of all if you have little programs
that are giving feedback to people and
manipulating them those programs well as
a matter of course cluster people into
groups that oppose each other
and this is just a natural optimization
this is like this is just a thing that
will happen it's it's not it doesn't
have to be planned and so then you start
organizing people into these opposing
groups and then they become annoyed with
each other they become more and more
addicted more and more involved but then
there's this other thing so I have I had
a hypothesis called the PAC switch and
so the notion is that people are similar
to say coyotes or some other animals
that can either function as loners or as
members of packs and when that switch is
turned inside of inside us and we feel
we're a member of a pack our whole sense
of perception our ethics our morality
our personality changes and it becomes
all about the pack and and what we must
do is avoid setting that switch we must
remain individuals in order to be decent
to each other when we turn into a mob
and this is what I meant by digital
maoism what was interesting to me about
some experiments on the left as well as
on the right is there were occasions
when people started with good intentions
but they ended up with this horrible
violence and these atrocities and I I
suspect what's happening as they under
appreciated this this switch that's
inside all of us so the question I asked
is if we start manipulating with these
digital loops why won't we create social
catastrophes of people turning on each
other turning tribal why won't this
destabilize society completely and this
is what I fear is happening this is some
of the outcome maybe we are seeing now
do you think well ultimately of what you
were writing in the 90s yeah it
certainly appears to me to be a
description of what's going on in the
u.s. now yeah what was it in the is it
the business model is the advertising
model is the algorithms they use are
they like betting company so they they
have these heart-stopping moments so
they are addictive you talked about they
did you talk about the addiction yeah
what is it that they are using a funny
thing happened last week there was an
interview of me published in the New
York Times about this addiction thing
and the next day one of the Facebook
founder Sean Parker came out and said
yeah actually we intentionally did that
which was an open secret everybody has
known that but now
the record so if you wish to addicted
creature you give them feedback in
exchange for the actions you wish them
to perform but slightly inconsistent
feedback so that it's not too mechanical
so they have to keep on grasping it how
to get there to make the feedback more
more consistent so if you have a rat in
a behaviorist experiment and the rat is
supposed to hit a button to get a treat
sometimes it works sometimes it does and
sometimes it's a little delayed and you
have to vary it a little bit to get the
rat super obsessed with how to really
get this thing going
and people find it hard to resist that
and so if you set up a feedback loop
with that quality you redic to people
and this is something casinos know all
about this is something Kahneman know
all about and we formalized it into code
or well you know Facebook did and some
of the other social media companies and
it it's a it's a legacy of behaviorist
research in manipulating behavior and
and this is something that can be done
but should not be done we can't have a
decent society we can't have people with
their own volition we can't have a
society that progresses we can't have a
society based on empathy or kindness if
people are constantly being manipulated
from some central source no matter what
type of source that is do you think it
was a cynical act was it a cynical act
to build a business cuz you said Google
are your friends they bought one of your
businesses they are you know they are
people that have brought also abroad of
course great wealth and to not just to
themselves but to let people know I mean
it's the most spectacular and quick
wealth creation in history I mean if you
look at the list of the world's
wealthiest individuals now most of them
especially the new ones are close to
some digital hub of some kind you know
that that's where the wealth is now I
can't speak to whether it was cynical
because I was not there I it's I suspect
it was more sort of like kids goofing
around and being sort of bad boys I'm
not taking it too seriously and then it
kind of took off a nice little stuff
that what yeah I mean I think what
happens is if you have a spectacular
level of success especially when you're
young you take it as some kind of
message from the universe and maybe you
lose your standards a little bit I'm not
sure though I that in that I real I
wasn't there so that one I don't really
know about I can't speak to it and what
about some solutions to that and what we
could now do as users of these sites
what is it that needs to to happen to
break this relationship well I mean I
think there's a few things that everyone
is obligated to do and its work honestly
it's not like it's not super easy okay I
should make clear I'm speaking only for
myself I mentioned that I have a
connection with Microsoft when I'm out
doing my books I have a very strict
boundary and I say things that are
definitely not Microsoft approved
Microsoft owns a social network called
LinkedIn and yet I'm about to tell you
delete all your social media accounts
just stop don't do it it's stupid stop
doing it you think that you're just
having fun watching your favorite
whatever football team or keeping up
with with relatives you're being watched
you're being manipulated just stop doing
it get off it figure out some other way
to do those things you're smart but it
is you don't have to do it but it's
there a way is there a way though is it
right where I've never been on one I
don't face I just seem to be able to
sell books I mean I don't I think this
this whole notion that if you don't do
it you'll be left out in the cold and
you'll die it's wrong I think you all
you have to do is simply stop and life
is fine do you think that with
[Music]
but surely these social media companies
or let's Facebook or weather orb or
other technology companies have also
brought great advantages to the world
surely and and maybe from the West and
maybe are slightly comfortable audience
here maybe we can delete it but if
you're a you're a campaigner in Syria
and Facebook can actually link you to
the world that was a very good thing
well see what happens is there's a
pattern to how this works and this is
actually in a way we're getting into
what I'm writing about in a follow-on
book that isn't announced this isn't
really in the present book but the
pattern is that initially people who are
trying to do good works and there are
spectacular good works that occur over
social media and I could talk about the
me2 movement right now which i think is
doing a lot of good but that one hasn't
played out yet so let me talk about
black lives matter from an earlier time
okay so with black lives matter you had
a social media campaign that really did
raise awareness about a horrible
phenomenon in the US were unarmed young
black men typically or other other
people of color would be end up dead
after what seemed like a routine traffic
stop and it just kept on happening and
happening in various variations and so
initially there was this extraordinary
success of the social media aspect of
black lives matter people got together
they organized but the thing is while
they were doing that and there's and I'm
not in any sense questioning the
validity of it and in fact I'll even go
further and I'll say in the u.s. black
Twitter as a social phenomenon itself as
a sort of form of literature spectacular
and beautiful and an amazing thing all
of that is true the problem is that
simultaneously with that the algorithms
are classifying all these people who are
participating in it as well as other
people who are reacting and then
gradually it turns those two groups
against each other because if we can use
them to annoy each other it increases
engagement which is its prime directive
so then a little later on suddenly black
lives matter is turned into this thing
that's used to annoy and engage this
other group meanwhile other groups are
used to annoy and engage black lives
matter that all just happens as a matter
of course
the functioning of the algorithms whose
job is to maximize engagement but then
when people come along who are saboteurs
who and there were this whole business
of sort of bad actors is a really
interesting thing there all kinds of bad
actors the ones we're talking about now
quite a bit are Russian intelligence
services that wish to intervene in the
US but they're also sometimes just nasty
people weirdo rich people who want to
prove they can change the world
sometimes they're organized-crime
interests that get involved in one way
or another the metaphor I like for
understanding the role of all of these
bad actors is they're the gut bacteria
of social media they're this other force
that co-evolved with social media that
provides a lot of energy and motion and
momentum that wouldn't be there
otherwise and so there's a codependence
anyway when these bad actors come in
they see that the algorithms are
starting to divide people to increase
engagement and then all they have to do
is latch on that and they can make it
worse and worse so suddenly black lives
matter became a fulcrum for for harming
the society for tearing it apart for
making people crazy and paranoid for
making no one trust anything no one know
what's no one could tell it's true
anymore everything became more and more
crazy so despite the the validity and
the beauty of the initial wave which is
always there it's then followed up by
something that's completely degrading
and disruptive and ridiculous and
disconnected from reality so the
question is will this happen to the me2
movement now and the answer is yeah
probably because that's how this works
so there's a powder is a natural
polarization a deliberate polarization
well what is it okay let me ask you what
engages you so if I if I come to you and
I say oh what a pretty flower you might
say oh that is a lovely flower and if I
say hey that guy over there saying he
wants to kick you engage you more like
the potential for adversity the
potential for social opposition is
terribly engaging to this social species
that we are it just gets us immediately
so it just by the mere fact that it's
the more engaged response it's the one
that the algorithms end up choosing so
turn off
your social media let's say that doesn't
influence the billions of people on
social media immediately what are the
solutions well maybe in here that's it
that's a couple of thousands of kicks
off it but but what about now you've
talked about that they should actually
as well things like you need to
undermine the business model where we
with micro payments with different
systems for influencing how these
algorithms and business models work so
right now the first inclination of a lot
of people is to take a regulatory
approach and there there's probably a
role for that but it seems to me the
more intelligent initial approach would
be to change the perverse incentives of
the business model so if the current
business model is you don't sell
anything you don't pay anybody all of
your business happens with unseen third
parties we're paying to manipulate the
people who are engaged with you if
there's some alternative to that
business model it should be pursued and
the one I've been interested in is just
you know pay people and expect to be
paid like turn it into a business since
that's what it is so one could imagine a
future version of something like
Facebook where you pay a very small fee
because it really would be very small or
if you're impoverished you could fall
into a class where you pay no fee or
something
so how that's worked out but then you
also have a chance to earn money so if
you get a lot of traction you get
followers or for whatever the measure is
you can start earning back I think a
fairly substantial number of people
would end up with a nice income from
that not everybody obviously it has to
be a minority but so but the thing is if
every service did that there'd be this
distribution of different clusters of
people who could make a living and I
think that could create a society where
a lot of people did very well for their
authentic contributions and I think
that's a more dignified and balanced and
creative and future looking society than
some sort of crazy thing where we say we
pretend you're all useless even though
you aren't and then give you all a basic
income so you're Ward's of the state and
then just tell you to shut up which is
the fantasy and I think it's a horrible
vision
and you've taught as well about in your
early career in virtuality this sort of
this sort of hippie notion this may be
left notion but then interestingly you
have been very critical of what may be
some slightly more ignorant of the
systems that are used things like
Wikipedia and also open source how how
does that fit into this picture you know
you know cuz Wikipedia was was meant to
be this really nice thing you know Jimmy
Wells is a nice guy he tried his best he
was kind of just you know being able to
go to build a system that allow people
to share expertise um I have to say that
at this late date when we're seeing the
democracies of the world slowly
succumbed to tribalism and turned into
autocracies and as we're seeing that my
old criticisms of the Wikipedia and open
source seem quaint don't they I mean I
at the time what I was concerned with
Wikipedia was the promotion of a it's
it's the ratio of the personal point of
view like instead of having an author
you say no this is the official article
describing this topic so there's a thing
called the Encyclopedia Britannica and
an encyclopedia Americana they might
have different articles for the same
topic but they announced their
perspective and since this notion of a
global perspective is a fiction and
dangerous in many fields it the
Wikipedia also had the effect of
shutting down creative communication in
some fields where there could be
objectivity for instance the practically
the day that Wikipedia took off a whole
bunch of people who were doing really
creative presentations of math online
suddenly lost traffic and then we ended
up with this very nerdy sort of standard
math resource that I think excludes
people so I thought it was a
well-intentioned experiment with some
good qualities but also something of a
failure I should say that shortly after
my criticisms were published both of the
founders of the Wikipedia endorsed them
so it's not like I was some sort of
weird critic off on the side if they
Wade lijjat had a tendency towards
monopoly so Wikipedia starts sucking out
other org and Google and Facebook this
tendency to monopoly which is was oddly
contradictory to the world you started
off in when there's this notion of let a
thousand ideas flourish
you know people can pick them yeah so um
digital network effects do create these
very intense monopolistic outcomes and
it's totally avoidable but you know and
and this is actually where the economics
comes in so if if your only business
model is to manipulate people then what
you your your you must engage engage
engage if your business model is selling
them something then you might find some
niche where you engage only some of them
in a very special way that's highly
profitable you don't have to be monopoly
anymore so this sort of strange thing is
that if we deny people access to a
normal marketplace of goods and services
and demand that they function within the
behavior modification loop Empire you
naturally will create monopolies because
that's that's the only Avenue available
to them sometimes feel a little bit of a
lonely voice if you look at Amazon
Google Facebook and their power and
their ability to constantly be telling
us what it is we need and then to
predict what it is we might need in the
future or do you still feel optimistic
well let me be clear about something
this this business model that I'm
decrying is actually a rather rare one
so if you believe that there's a top
five big tech companies to be concerned
with only two of them engage in this so
an Amazon Apple and Microsoft do a
little bit of it but they primarily sell
goods and services and they're all
somewhat diversified it's really Google
and Facebook and face Facebook primarily
who do this and and the result of that
is they've had very little success
diversifying so they're they're
massively addicted themselves to their
own addiction engine so you know when
you have a company that's like 90%
making their money from this one thing
it's a little troublesome for them in
the long term I would think there are
other companies that do this like
Twitter snap but I have to say like
Twitter is wobbly it's not even a great
business plan I mean it's really a very
localized it's I mean Facebook is a big
company with a lot of profit but it's
it's a very singular thing there are
plenty of reasons to be interested
like you could be upset for legitimate
reasons with all the other companies but
that's it but they're not for this
reason this is you know like there's a
little bit of this that happens in the
Amazon sales machine the way it runs its
reviews it's doing a little bit of that
to sell stuff but it's so much it's not
such people isn't it two wards it's
starting to nudge people towards making
different choices if you like that you
would like this yeah it's using them to
buy a different model of TV or something
this is not going to tear civilization
apart right you know so I so as far as
this discussion is going you can there
are I'm sure legitimate criticisms of
the other ones but this is really very
specific to just a handful of companies
tell us a little bit about virtual
reality and mixed reality and virtuality
and give us some views about the way
this is going to develop because that is
the optimistic message that you have a
sense of where VR can kind of challenges
which I must admit I didn't understand
until reading your books and some of
your interviews that that you believe
that VR can be a solution somebody's
what rather than just the exacerbation
of somebody's issue I can't believe
you've never had occasion to try it no I
know that's terrible and I mean I
wrestle I'm gonna get the BBC BBC as
this big VR afraid II haven't yep get
with it man - I'm too boring doing
economic spreadsheets all I need - yeah
I'll do it baby yeah okay actually how
many people in here I've done VR pretty
regular not just once but pretty
regularly that's a small number but
you're in EM Britain know we're still
horse and carts outside yeah yeah well
the thing is I mean but the audiences
are literate and so in the US all the
hands would be up and I would I don't
know I mention the EM Forster and I
mention iam forced her by the way
because in something like 110 years ago
he wrote a novella called the machine
stops that essentially just described
the the dilemma we're in the one I just
described with remarkable clarity so
long ago so if you want to prescient
warning go to your own writers
but anyway but today's the ultimate
battle so let me let me do the
optimistic thing maybe I'll start with a
very simple question is there such a
thing as making a virtual reality system
that's good enough for all time you make
goggles that are so good that they
outpace the retina for a number of
detectable points you make very high
quality sensors and I won't go into the
details since you haven't even tried it
but but basically they're all these
components so so some people say if you
make all this stuff good enough then
you're done you have a VR system that
will fool people but see I think that's
wrong because I think what happens is
with each stage of development in VR
people get used to it and then their
powers of perception increase and stay
ahead so the thing is that the big
mistake we make for better or for worse
and it goes both ways is to think of
ourselves as fixed quantities the
optimism we need to have in ourselves
and the remarkable thing about people is
our elasticity that we can grow and
change we can learn to perceive in new
ways we can become smarter with
experience so as you start to use the
latest VR you start to you get it you
know I have an 11-year old daughter
who's done a lot of VR and she's really
not impressed anymore and I think that's
great you know she does she end up doing
it no she still enjoys it but she's not
impressed right like there has to be
some really beautiful or good design the
the thing itself is really old to her
and I see this a lot with with VR use
and I think that's actually a very
positive quality so what I think we have
in order for our in order to overcome
the illusions of Technology we have to
engage in it in such a way that we learn
and grow and see through the illusions
let's say I'll compare it to magic which
reality is kind of like a silicon
version of stage magic if you like so
one thing to say is that the difference
between a charlatan and a magician is
that the magician announces the trick
and social media has failed to announce
its tricks they had the shamans yeah one
of the things I love about vert reality
is that there are these ugly awkward
headsets they announce the trick so this
this this big thing on your head is the
announcement it makes it ethical I
really worry about it becoming some
little thing where you might not realize
it's there I think that might be
unethical so Google Glasses is not you
know started by my friend who I sold the
company with yeah yeah I don't like the
Google glass design I think trying to
make it disappear is ridiculous it also
doesn't work because like the more
you're trying to hide it the more it
stands out like a pimple or something
it's like oh yeah you're trying to hide
that thing but there's this thing on
your face it's ridiculous like just wear
the big awkward thing look ugly it's
okay
and then but but so the trick should be
announced but the other thing is if you
know how a trick works you can still
enjoy a magician right because there's
an art to it it's not so much that that
knowing the trick is everything it's
it's the presentation and VR should be
the same way like people have to become
educated and also there could be
something very similar to social media
that doesn't have the perverse
manipulation incentive at the core of it
that could achieve all the good social
media does without this horrible
backlash that always comes afterwards
this is all very doable but it can't be
done from a central planning station you
can say oh Silicon Valley fix this for
us I mean the way this can work it's
just like with democracy people have to
take responsibility to become literate
in a new way if they're going to use the
technology at all so for God's sakes if
you just can't find it in yourselves to
delete all your social media accounts
then you must take it upon yourself to
really learn how it works learn how the
addiction cycle works learn how their
manipulation works become more aware of
it if you can't make one of those two
choices you're becoming a drone and
you're not fully functioning as a
citizen in the new world and and I mean
I have to be very blunt about that those
are the choices available to you there
are no others
do you worry down there that
do you worry that VR itself is also
isolating and can also when I see my two
children with their headsets on we
wonder well guess what headsets and
you've never tried yes I know this is
embarrassing anyway oh but I'm you know
we could we can take this outside join
later but when I see my children and I
wonder why are they outside playing with
you know wooden train sets I mean they
are 17 and 30 and so Asli that's not
that interesting but you know I used to
play with Lego with my mates and they're
sitting there playing whatever it is
with their friends but no friend I
appeal to your kids you give your dad a
demo already well show you here let's
move on from my complete failure onto my
case but you know what I mean it's this
notion that you have great artistry in
explaining how VR can touch us again
with the notion of our artistry and you
touched on surrealism at the beginning
of our talk but it's not VR itself and
also mixed reality essentially isolating
because you you closed that the goggles
that you can see close yourself off so I
want to address that in the book I
describe how I early on had this
completely electrifying luminous
realization that this could be this path
to shared dreaming that I dreamed of
when I was in my early teens and it was
it kept me going for a few years and
then I had exactly the opposite
revelation so how many of you have heard
of Norbert Wiener okay that's pretty
good
so Norbert Wiener is one of the first
generation of computer scientists
possibly the first person to write well
about computer science even though it's
it from the present perspective it's a
little dense and hard to get into in his
vocabulary and framework er a little
difficult but writing starting in the
40s he was concerned with exactly the
problem we have here of creating control
loops with computers that would
manipulate people one of his books is
called the human use of human beings
which foresees this problem at the end
of it he has this very comforting note
that in order for
the thing he's describing to actually be
problematic we'd have to have devices
with us all the time that we'd interact
with frequent frequently that would
provide us with some kind of feedback
and they'd all have to attach to some
kind of global information system even
without cables and that that was
unfeasible so this is purely a thought
experiment and you read this from 1948
and it's it's it's terrifying and tragic
so what I realized is that if if what
we're concerned about is that you could
use technology to put somebody inside a
skinner box or inside a behavior
modification device that would involve
measuring the person and providing them
with feedback and what by definition is
the technology that does the most
precise measurements of what's going on
with a person and provides the most
comprehensive feedback why it's exactly
virtual reality so what I realized is
that this thing I look forward to that I
viewed as a kind of almost like an
existential solution to my crisis
something I've just profound beauty and
importance to me could also be the
evilest invention of all time like it
actually has both identities and it
continues to and unfortunately the
fiction of vert reality has a bit been
bit a bit more attuned to this very
valid negative possibility and I'm
thinking of say the Matrix movies as an
example but there are many other
examples we might also mention the
feeley's if you remember this this whole
this whole notion that people will
people will choose to live in this vr
world rather than to live and to tackle
the real world around them with may they
not well I mean what I hope is that so
this gets back to this this issue if
people are able to change and grow in
response then they'll stay ahead of the
technology and they won't but if they're
if they're addicted and they're put in a
loop based on central control from
somewhere else and then yes we could
have a very negative scenario so what it
all boils down to is where's the locus
of control are you in charge of your own
life or is there some central planner
who's in charge of what you see what you
do and right now we've sort of tended to
say well it's some Silicon Valley
company it's not a government so that
must make it okay
but the the general structure is simply
not acceptable it's not survivable so I
virtuality can go either way the way
I've been thinking about it lately is in
a way we're quite lucky that we're
facing these issues during a period of
kind of really crude digital technology
because right now I mean what you get
with social media or really anything you
can get on your phone for the most part
is really pretty crude it's like as
messages and pictures and videos and an
occasional little VR thing on your phone
that's very minimal because you can't
really interact through it so this is a
super low tech crude version of digital
interaction and so it's not very intense
yet and it still is bad enough to
disrupt the world's democracies so what
we should we need to figure this out
before it gets more intense and if I may
I'd like to foresee a thought that I bet
some people have which is if there's so
much peril why don't we turn away from
it why are we going down this path and
here there's a very good answer which is
we're compelled to from the earliest
state that we started to make technology
from when we started making fires and
the you know in planting seeds every new
technology has been absolutely essential
in order for compassionate reasons so
that there would be fewer infant deaths
let's say and and yet each one created
its own new problems and so once we go
down this path we're compelled to
continue to improve there's no way to
just get to some static level of
Technology and say we're done it just
doesn't work that way there's this
constant of sort of back and forth the
sort of a dialectic of technological
investment advancement that you simply
cannot withdraw from and survive and and
this business of having better digital
communications better way of visualizing
complexity better way of better ways of
interacting is is compulsory it's not
it's not an option so we have to figure
out a way and this this is an
interesting question that might not seem
so to you but if anyone wants to argue
about it we can do in a question time
yeah so so we must go down this path but
we have to get ourselves in we have to
remove the perverse incentives and
try to come up with some structure
that's survivable before it gets really
intense kind of saucy a final question
before well there's gonna be one little
interlude who's gonna be an unusual one
but before we get to questions as well
do you think that the Facebook's of this
world the Google's of the world will get
what you would suggest is their social
responsibility to actually change or is
it up to us to enforce that change on
them Mark Zuckerberg or do you think
he's many people say it's not a bad
person well you know I I know some of
the other early Facebook people like
Sean Parker and Peter Thiel but I've
never met Zuckerberg so but all my sense
of him from my my indirect sense is that
he's a perfectly nice person so I would
expect him the only way for this sort of
transition to happen is in concert
everybody has to work together so if if
Facebook just tells everybody oh from
now on you're gonna pay for your
subscription won't work out some way you
get paid I think a lot of people say you
know I think that would be but if if
people want it at the same time that
Facebook does it there's a way to nudge
the whole world together I think that's
feasible and if you say oh no that's
that's too hard such a things never
happened I just want to remind you that
very recently this hall would have been
filled with cigarette smoke very
recently the speed outside would have
been covered with litter very recently
the world was different and we all just
decided to change it and we did this is
something people can do we've done it
before we can do it now that's an
optimistic note to finish off so before
I come to questions now it's not often I
can I can I can say this you're not only
a tech an amazing tech thinker and also
doer but also you have been a goatherd
at state your service true yes and a
midwife midwife's assistant oh ok not
quite as good as this not bad crucial
distinction believe me and also you are
a great player of ancient instruments
and I believe if I'm polite enough to
you you might be encouraged to play the
lower Asian mouth organ before this
fabulous audience yes that is correct
and you have indeed been sufficiently
wide
I just Segway it into that
so yeah there's this instrument I
sometimes like I like to play music when
I'm the public events and this one is
generally a pretty effective one and I
can get it on carrion which is important
these days so okay this is someone I
don't know this is the size of a bustle
the size of a small I haven't played
this either just like VR I'm done that
there's another thing I'm done where
does this thing come from Laos no I mean
on the stage not necessary which country
there it is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
questions gentlemen here we'll start
with sorry I'm shouting with others it
could have been ever excited with the
old mouth woman there is there is a
microphone coming down could we get some
microphones down here
it better be great oh it's not me
through water start we'll start up this
negative you've got someone at number
three yeah let's go yeah hi Jaron
and it's really interesting I suppose my
my question is given some of the I won't
say paranoia dozen teachers some of the
practicalities around what you're
talking around in terms of social media
how far down the rabbit hole do you
think we're gonna end up going with the
introduction of quantum computing and
how far away do you think that is oh god
quantum computing question I feel this
might exclude some people in the
audience but well we're taught does
everybody know what we're talking about
so there's a kind of computer that was
formalized by touring once again local
reference and it's it that that
abstraction describes every computer
you've used your phone and everything
else but there's this other sort of a
computer that could exist that uses the
principles of quantum effects and the
the way this is the way this works let's
say you have a bunch of particles and
each of them might be one way or another
way they have different properties like
spin and stuff there's only a
probability that some combination of
those properties will be true provided
they're connected together and a certain
particles are connected in a certain way
and what but the number of probabilities
is very large because there's one
probability for each possible
combination and so if you're very very
tricky you can actually use that
extended set of probabilities as a new
kind of computer memory but you have to
be very tricky indeed but hypothetically
we might be able to build these things
so that we can perform much more
elaborate computations because there's
all this extra memory from this range of
probabilities it's a very strange idea
there are a lot of different ideas about
how to do it
Google's doing this one where they put a
bunch of quantum bits together and they
all kind of find their way to a balance
together which is called a never mind I
won't go into that and we're doing this
other one where we get them to type
Microsoft we're doing this one where we
get them to tie little knots together so
it's in logically it so anyway they're
all these different ways to do it it
might be able to do crazy stuff like
solve problems that are currently
inaccessible break codes that you know
all kinds of stuff wait a few years to
see if this thing is really working I
mean like I it's kind of exciting right
now a lot of the basics are starting to
work does it have anything to do with
virtual reality yeah sure I mean sure he
could make really interesting virtual
worlds with it I'm sure we can make all
kinds of fantastic things it's it's just
a bit early I you know what I found with
technology is that there's some visions
you can have far in advance and then
there's other ways that the particulars
present themselves as you get closer and
I think with quantum stuff we've all
been talking about it for decades
there's all these fantastic predictions
we're getting so close to getting some
sense of the particulars that I think we
should just shut up now and find out
what it's actually like to the degree we
can get it to work we're very close to
having some answers but it basically
just boosts computer power hugely if it
could be made to work I mean I
interviewed Satya Nadella here and he
said the quantum mechanic imputing was
one of the big things that Microsoft
would be pushing on because it could end
that kind of Moore's law all they've
been living with us so long and actually
changed substantially the power of
computing in terms of creating right but
it'll be very quirky it won't make every
kind of computation faster it'll be very
quirky particular ones and so there so
it'll have a very particular quality or
deaths I think that's the most likely
outcome
okay question Donna hi so assuming that
staggering level of incompetence
continues and that we're not able to
correct the systems currently in play
what does the decline look like and what
is the safest sort of route for an
individual to take to try and navigate
it yeah that's a that's a rather dark
question I will point out that many of
the wealthiest and most powerful people
in Silicon Valley routinely like if
we're just meeting they'll say some
horrible things one of them is so have
you got that back-up plan in New Zealand
together and I'm like no we can't cut a
New Zealand like our responsibility is
to stay here and make this work like New
Zealand is a fine place but that's that
we can't treat it as some kind of escape
hatch so I we must make this work I
don't know how difficult or horrible the
path towards it will be for the moment
the trolls are winning for the moment
the trolls have destabilized my country
terribly but I want to point out that we
have faced much more difficult problems
in the past and come through you know
like for all the problems we face now at
least so far I mean I don't know where
this will go it could get worse of
course I would imagine that Mike just
because the way things go it's likely to
get worse before it gets better but
would it get as bad as I don't know
world war two I don't I don't think so
and we made it through that right so I'm
not optimistic in the sense that
problems will be easy and that no one
will be heard and that it will be a
breeze and all we have to do is just
suddenly have the right idea and the
problem I don't think it's like that I
think we're actually facing a real
difficulty my sense is that they're a
handful of techie problems this century
that will be very hard to solve that we
simply must solve so climate change
carbon footprint is one of them nuclear
proliferation is another one dangerous
of biotech is another one and this is
another one of those so we have multi
which makes it harder to deal with each
one individually and yet we must we
simply must I mean I I simply won't
entertain the thought that we won't we
will period that's it we'll do it but I
think it'll be difficult someone the
back there did you say is there someone
there oh sorry I have oh yeah sorry Mike
hi and how do you think virtual reality
should regulate acts in real life that
would be illegal such as rape or snarf
or pedophilia yeah I this is a really
this is a really tricky one a friend of
mine in in the States just put out a
movie where at the end all these
characters eat a baby you probably know
what I'm talking about
and I was like you made a movie where
people you ate a baby what are you doing
and and so you know it's a metaphor for
how we're mistreating the earth okay
so the it's the difficulty with media is
that context is everything and although
it might be hard to construct I'm a
little concerned about creating specific
prohibitions on things because we don't
know how to describe what we're really
talking about that should be prohibited
and yet at the same time Oh God in this
but I have to say something which is
that our particular tech culture has
been kind of overrun largely I think
because of the phenomenon I was
discovered I was discussing just now I
think it's been quite overrun with a
kind of this sort of crude and
[Music]
reductionist and sort of insecure
version of masculinity that I really
reject that we see in things like the
well gamergate if you know what that is
and I think it's turned into the alt
right and it's a I think what it is is
it's what happens to masculinity when
it's being manipulated by
real modification live you become like
really nervous and kind of paranoid and
kind of like jittery and it's also known
sometimes as the snowflake persona and
there's I think we see it in our
president in America we see it in
college students and kids sometimes it's
it's the personality outcome but anyway
since that's become so powerful I am
very strongly tempted just to reject my
impulse to not try to regulate and say
no actually right now maybe just in this
circumstance we should because playing
with the stuff is too dangerous and I
have to tell you you've asked a hard
question that I struggle with every day
I think it is a really tricky one I've
seen some things invert reality that I
don't think should have been there one
of them was sprung on my daughter once
in a way that was truly offensive and
damaging and and and and just on some
service that somebody had done in a sort
of a sadistic way and I feel very upset
about it
[Music]
so you know it's this is a really tricky
thing I do believe quite strongly that
[Music]
the first duty is to fix the incentives
rather than regulate so if you ask why
are all the why are there all these
horrible like terrorism videos and
whatnot on YouTube why is there all this
all the false that the fake news which I
prefer to call [ __ ] posting which is the
term of art used by the people who pay
for it is can I say that here your a lot
said yeah yeah okay so sorry but it is
actually the term of art that's what
it's called and and the thing is it's
because the underlying incentive
structure is for so-called engagement
and evil engages you know it just does
if you're scared if you're offended if
you're worried about your kids if you're
worried about your partner these things
really engage you so therefore they're
selected for so I do believe that if the
incentive was changed that would at
least be a first line of defense to
reduce the the occurrences of these
things I have I
not a researcher in this particular
field but I have friends who've studied
this question of whether violent video
games or pornography etc tend to have an
what effect they have on behavior
subsequently and what's really
interesting is that it's not a simple
answer with people who seem to have
certain pre-existing situations it can
it can lead to worse and worse behavior
and we've unfortunately since we also
have a gun culture in the u.s. we've
seen horrible horrible outcomes from
that in other cases it seems to be just
a sort of a strange aesthetic thing for
a person that doesn't really correspond
to behavioral changes just like people
who like horror movies or you know and
and so the process so anyway you've
asked a very difficult question I'm
question officer came from quite a lot
what's your thought on on how the
technology the social media technology
world deals with some of those issues
not not very well but I want to use VR a
couple of times so but my hunches and
the research I've seen in relation to I
don't think it was the NSPCC but other
related companies that look at
pedophilia entities that look at
pedophilia have shown it does it isn't a
way for pedophiles to let out what they
need to let out it encourages it by
normalizing it so I suspect that l-cut
tech culture and governments will
respond too late to this and that it
will be a problem yeah because it is a
very difficult thing to regulate yeah
this is a this is a big issue I mean I
thank you because there is this issue of
masculinity in Silicon Valley
yeah and that the place is run or lots
large parts of Silicon Valley are run by
a certain type of masculine character
bullying misogynistic sometimes and it
has led to a development of of certain
types of contact yeah that's absolutely
correct and
it's one of the worst things I mean I
really do you put it down to that it has
that Silicon Valley is such a male
dominate well I think it has a little
bit to do with the technology being so
closely aligned with a certain kind of
obsessive cognitive and an insecure
cognitive style I I I hate to say it
this way because I don't want it to
reflect poorly on people on the spectrum
but it does have like a little toe in
the spectrum and there's a there's a
kind of a oversimplification of the
world and Yanks it's hard stuff yeah
hello yes sorry I just wanted to kind of
follow up from that question because I
feel like really what it's tapping into
is this bigger idea of I guess
censorship and technology and the
responsibility that tech brands really
have because I was reading the article
the other day which is talking about how
Twitter's regulations had gone from
protecting free speech to protecting
users from emotional harm and that
transition and I wonder where you see
that going next and how you think tech
brands can because you know emotional
safety of users of really important
things so how do you what's next for so
they can finally how can they protect
their users while at the same time
protecting free speech so I think the
answer looks approximately like this
I I don't like the feeling that we keep
on going to a very small number of big
tech companies on the west coast of the
United States and saying oh great tech
companies protect us from this and that
like you need to protect us from the
bullies you need to protect us from the
pedophiles need to protect us from the
terrorists need to protect us from from
the Russian manipulators need to protect
us from the fake news people because at
a certain point we're asking them to run
our culture and I think there is a
better way
and and and I'm sorry to sound like a
broken record on this but if instead of
having free services controlled by these
central authorities whether they be you
know that are companies like Facebook or
Twitter if instead there was a monitor
monetized system then there would be a
role for intermediaries to survive
within that system so instead of just
going to the big wide world of the whole
internet you would have a multitude of
intermediary some of whom would become
trusted and so the metaphor I'd make to
this is that right now somebody can
print a hard flyer saying horrible
things and throw it on the street or
paste it up but it won't get much
distribution because most people so you
know read legitimate newspapers on paper
even though paper can be used to
distribute all the most awful things and
so what's happened is there's been an
itch for people newspapers magazines
whatever to generate reputations to
become trusted and to become curators
right instead of one central authority
like the government being asked to do
that which i think is a horrible idea so
if we had a monetized Internet then I
think there would be a niche for more of
these intermediate curators a variety of
them would be able to build reputations
instead of one centralized all-powerful
source that we petitioned and asked to
run our culture for us I'm really quite
concerned about this tendency of
demanding that the tech companies
enforce things because as well
intentioned as each case is and as
important as each one is every time we
give them this Duty we're also giving
them more power we're telling them we
think you Facebook should decide what
you know how to run the culture and even
if in each case what we're saying is
absolutely defensible and and and you
know
absolutely beyond dispute in that case
cumulatively we're asking them to take
more and more power over the culture
now remember facebook is owned and
controlled by one person even though
it's a public company so who knows who's
gonna inherit it
what if Vladimir Putin inherits it then
we've given it all this power and and
this is what I mean to use Russia as
another example whenever there's super
centralized power it tends to get worse
over time Bolsheviks were cuter than
Stalinists let's say okay there's
there's this path where power corrupts
that it gets worse and worse so as we as
we're trying to fix these problems by
petitioning the big Silicon Valley
companies we're also concentrating their
authority implicitly and I think we're
setting ourselves up for even worse
problems in the future so I'm really
uncomfortable with this pattern now and
so you say well the Silicon Valley
company should be more responsible but
should they I mean what should actually
happen is they're shipping niches for
other people there should be a a world
of intermediaries to build reputations
and this notion that we're depending on
these centralized sources is is crazy I
mean would you like it becomes similar
to a state media at that point and jaren
I've got a question for my children it's
about Google and the search and the
commercialization search where do you
think the solution is in the future
because I know that when my kids look on
Google they just get commercialized
search they're not really finding out
half the world that they should and how
do we change that this is so crazy
yeah so basically on Google what you do
is you get one Wikipedia entry and
Wikipedia doesn't make enough money from
that they're struggling so that's that's
an injustice and then you get a zillion
stores a tenth of a penny per search
would you be willing to pay that but if
you got it like a five dollar bill at
the end of the month given the volume
that Google makes a very small billing
cycle for for their services would
completely overwhelm what they call the
advertising market so it'd be better for
them better for
they're shareholders and then all you do
is you say I'm paying you I demand
actual results and not a bunch of
commercial nonsense and it that seems
like just a more intelligent solution
let me see that yeah hi I wonder what
you thought of the similarities and
differences with the Chinese tech
companies oh yeah that's really
interesting you know what happened as
China was looking at what's happening in
Silicon Valley and they were like yeah
this is great
this is what we want and so the the
Chinese tech companies look a lot like
Silicon Valley companies I mean if you
go to visit I don't know 10 cent or
something these these companies feel
like Google and Facebook they are closer
to the state than the American versions
but they have a similar amount of power
they have they do enforce content they
do they do you know and the way they
enforce it is possibly something we
would like sometimes and often something
that I think is unconscionable they're
terrible on the history of TM on men
they're terrible on Tibet and many other
issues and I think it's a injustice to
the people of China but that's what they
have and I have to say we gave them the
model it's not like somebody was reading
Marx and saying oh yeah we should build
this information system it was it was
really they were they were copying us
you know so I I don't know where that
goes in China I'm really interested in
that hi first of all thanks for the talk
is very informative you talked a lot
about manipulation of behavior and you
share your anxieties about
centralization of content or idea
whether the authority is state or
cooperate but I feel like I do commit
correct me if I'm wrong but I feel like
there's a sense of individualization of
a problem that is fundamentally systemic
because the solutions you propose which
are I'm in knowing thing in no way am I
saying
back is like individuals should be aware
about these things we should maybe turn
off or like hey like it's been less time
on social media and you know take the
initiative to change to change our
behavior but how much of these is
possible without challenging
fundamentally the logic of say the
economy because I've I think the most
systemic of solutions that you have
proposed is sort of in a way extending
the market model through the whole
internet monetizing it as you say but
that doesn't challenge the logic
fundamentally that you need to make
profit and what say Facebook do they the
algorithm is designed in a way to like
for ad revenues or whatever like they
need these ways to generate profit that
sustains their business and without
challenging how businesses work just
broadening it and having more actors can
can is that strong enough to like
prevent the wave of monopolization from
happening and is there really a
sustainable solution well you know what
happened I feel that our period now is
somewhat similar to the gilded ages of
the late 19th century in early 20th
century that unfortunately preceded
world wars where there was an untenable
concentration of Monopoly wealth and
influence in that case around things
like railroads and resource natural
resources and so transportation
resources and in our case it's around
information services and eventually
after these horrible wars we ended up
with the regime that created this
comfortable period of improved
circumstances for vast number of people
and it included a regulatory part which
was antitrust and other things and it
included social programs that included
us just societal change and widespread
education all kinds of things some kind
of you know some kind of multivalent
program of that kind ought to be able to
come to pass beyond this that's much
better
so I don't believe that monetizing the
internet by itself would be some sort of
panacea that would solve everything I
just think that if you have such if you
have a monopoly of perverse intentions
at the core no amount of regulation or
correction is gonna undo that that's
just the first step that you have to
take so I viewed as a first step not a
last step and I I really believe it
actually be better for everybody this
isn't an attack on the companies I think
it's I think we need big tech companies
actually really like big tech companies
but I think this would make them better
I think this would make them more
sustainable and it would be more
positive for everybody involved you may
have answered this but we regulate
addictive drugs we regulate addictive
services like gambling do you think we
should regulate addictive algorithms
yeah and you know the good thing in this
case is that we can define them more
clearly basically if there is a feedback
route from measurement of you that
affects the so called customized or
whatever feed and if anybody can pay to
influence that that is precisely the
thing to outlaw so I think we can we can
detect it we and I think it should be
outlawed I mean we can't do it instantly
because we need to give everybody a
chance to come up with other ways of
doing things but I think it I think
that's where we should end up I think
that that's a that's the government to
do well I think by whatever means
presumably government it might vary in
different parts of the world but but
that should be considered an immoral and
unethical configuration that should not
exist I would see hi there thank you so
much for the presentation was fantastic
my first question I think it's mainly
touched on before but you mentioned how
you would have Internet services being
monetized so that the ad revenue
wouldn't be the driving force behind the
algorithms that spy on us anymore but
wouldn't the algorithms still remain
there only a fundamental part of many of
these systems for example Facebook you
know suggesting you friends only knows
that by looking at the people you your
friends were currently and then
looking at who their friends would and
so on how would these algorithms be
changed even if the systems have become
monetized they would I mean the broad
question is that they should cease to
exist I think there are unethical
algorithms but I think something very
similar to them could be ethical I mean
this is the thing is that you could have
a version of all this stuff that's just
like three percent different that could
be much better so if if there's an
algorithm that's so this thing about
finding your friends my algorithm is
that it then starts to do little
experiments on so like let's say it's
it's found a closed peer community for
you and then it'll observe small
differences where one member in that
peer community sees something that's in
bright green and has a certain kind of
reference or something and then it'll
notice that that got that got somebody
upset then they'll start trying it on
more of you and then I'm similar so in
the very act of doing the suggestion
you're entering into this cycle that
then leads to more manipulation later
even though and I want to emphasize I
this might sound like these are
dastardly effective algorithms they're
actually terrible the truth is that this
is all really crude and crappy and
barely works it only works to the
tiniest degree it's like but it's like
compound interest like if it can have
the slightest effect like it's a 1/10 of
a percent difference but then it kind of
accumulates over time it gradually
starts to change society so we're not
talking about some dastardly perfect
mind control we're talking about a
really clunky gradual system that's
often absurd ridiculous but it works
just barely enough to start to have an
impact right at the back there yep not
sure if this is exactly related but what
do you think will be the effect if any
of blockchain technology does everybody
know what blockchain is really so you
haven't you haven't heard of Nurit
wiener you haven't heard of ivan
sutherland and we don't battle we know
they don't know about quantum Queen but
they know about blockchain Oh
god it's so strange so for those of you
who don't know it's a scheme whereby you
use encryption to keep track of a series
of transactions in a way that no one
person can falsify anything so it
becomes like this public but still none
centralized and yet sort of reliable way
of keeping track of transactions and so
it's used at the basis of these new
crypto currencies like famously Bitcoin
so I want to address blockchain and
cryptocurrencies separately blockchain
are more broadly using cryptography
techniques as a way of sort of enforcing
laws or principles without a central
authority is potentially useful and
there might be great use cases for it if
the hope the method by which blockchain
works is deliberately inefficient it
spends a lot of computation to do things
which is why it's hard to violate but
given that we're facing a carbon
footprint problem doing that level of
increased computation on a global scale
would be unacceptable so if we're gonna
do it we'd have to find some sustainable
way to do it and I've often imagined
blockchain servers on the moon or
something like that in all seriousness
they like we just have to do it in a way
that doesn't screw up the climate
further so that's blockchain blockchain
is simply a technique that has certain
advantages and certain problems certain
applications but it's well known now
because it's just it's the thing that
ties together the various
cryptocurrencies and people want to be
able to talk about them without being
necessarily focused on just one of them
like Bitcoin or aetherium or something
and the problem here's this is actually
a bit of a mystery to me
every cryptocurrency that's been started
to my knowledge and there might be some
I don't know about because it's been
exploding lately so I might be I might
not have a comprehensive view but
they're all Ponzi schemes they're all
scams what happens is the people who
start it create a bunch of fake wealth
for themselves and other people turn
into real wealth by speculating and the
earlier you are in the better your
chances of coming out but there's always
that little chance you'll do well
so later speculators once them all do
well and this is called a Ponzi scheme
but the thing is because it's cool
it doesn't pop right away so it can go
for a really really long time but it's
terribly dangerous and terribly unfair
to most people and it creates the
spectacular wealth concentration in the
early people in particular the founders
and then we have a bunch of these things
they're based on their they're based on
this redic in my view ridiculous sort of
see the libertarian ideology of trying
to emulate the gold standard so there's
a fixed number of these of these
bitcoins or other ones I can that come
into existence and so that means instead
of having a currency that can grow as
capability grows to reflect to reflect
an increased economy that comes from
greater technological capability you
just have this fixed thing where you
have this fixed block with the founders
and everybody else is dividing up their
bitcoins and trading them it's a it's a
feudal model it's so it's incredibly
regressive and yet it's like this really
hip popular thing I don't know look at
it it's terrible oK we've just a very
talk we get two more questions
gotta go what up there and the one over
there just very quick hi there um you
talked briefly about your your sort of
childhood and stuff what I wanted to
know was some how did you first get into
computing and what was the technology
you first working with yeah I wanted to
ask you about take the conversation back
to virtual reality as experience through
the goggles and this sort of the
magician's trick being announced how do
you see that evolving in the future
because at present all virtual reality
is kind of authored it's finite in its
duration you kind of have a sort of
short or however long experience of it
and it's sort of limited by people's
ability to program and the perceptual
reality kind of varies depending on how
sophisticated that is so where does this
go in the future how does this become
your solution okay early computers first
and then me okay what did you put what
are you what do you learn on the first
computer I used they built
which was a really simple thing when I
was a kid as it happens where I grew up
was close to White Sands Missile Range
where the atomic bomb was first tested
and so there was an incredible early
computer science department at the
University nearby which was really
unusual and extraordinary stroke of luck
I described all this in the book if you
want to get it and I my early my early
programming experience was punching
these cards you'd feed these punched
cards to the computer and then in the
desert winds you would try to hold onto
your cards but instead they fly
everywhere and your program would be
dissipated never to be seen again
and then the computers were actually
pretty slow so you could fake it and
pretend that the computer had run in
order to fake your result and so we'd
have to do that so that was my first
experience with competing and then on on
the VR thing yeah this is you know I
kind of regret that we didn't do more on
VR specifically but it just seems that
these that all of these other issues are
so urgent and our times that they demand
immediate discussion so in terms of VR
everything you said is correct I can
give you a few models of it you might
want to look at have you seen something
called second life so this is an online
this was a big deal before the iPhone I
didn't transfer to the small screen so
it kind of lost its currency but this
was a sort of an online virtual world
that thousands of people could be in and
they all designed their own virtual
places and they bought and sold stuff so
had an economy as I discuss full
disclosure I was involved in it so I'm
probably biased wasn't perfect sometimes
people behave badly but not as badly as
in some other forms like we never had an
Isis like place there we never had we
never had like a I don't know I mean
like it wasn't as bad as what happens
and and if you if you look at that sort
of a model I think the crucial crucial
thing is to get away from thinking of
rich reality is this thing you download
that then it says packaged experience
it's a live thing one of my
disappointments in the current batch of
stores for vert reality content is
they're based on sort of video or game
content where you download this thing
and then you run it it should be more
like a cross between like Skype and a
costume ball like what should happen is
there should be a live real-time thing
with people who are skilled performer
we're sort of like the dungeon masters
or puppeteers who are good at making
things happen they should be able to
make a living by the way and it's really
all about person-to-person it's live
it's real-time I think it can do virtual
realities experience is almost never
even slightly interesting I really think
they because they all kind of get the
same after all and I think we've seen
the consequences of that I will go this
is a whole big thing but I think there's
a misunderstanding in the industry of
what makes vert reality magical and the
way it's being done now isn't human
centric enough it's a little bit too
much of like canned content and that's
just you to the habits of the tech
industry what your bad habits can they
be can we break out of that yeah yeah as
a final we're up to time sadly but give
us a final notion of where VR can go in
in that optimistic sense you've talked a
lot about you've been asked a lot about
the darker sides and the possibilities
but where can it go to connect with
human but it turns out that humans are
capable of taking on different bodies
because our brain remembers all the
different bodies that used to control
over hundreds of millions of years in
evolution so it's really quite flexible
it's quite plastic so you could turn
into some fast some fantastic alien
spider but more than that you can turn
into some crazy alien spider that's
actually two people at once so you can
oh I don't know you could join with a
lover say and jointly control this alien
spider and then you have to coordinate
your bodies to become like one creature
for the first time which is a form of
connection that's quite profound and has
never been available before and you get
better and better at it it doesn't get
old it's not like just a little novelty
it's like a thing that just cries out
for practice and for achieving
virtuosity and you can do that and it's
really an extraordinary treat and it's
all yours it's not served at you from
some stupid Russian hacker paying some
company so I think this this kind of
beauty this kind of profundity is
available and I hope you all get to
experience it you especially
jaron lanier thank you very much
thank you very much to intelligence
squared thank you to you the audience
Darren's new book the dawn of the new
everything is available outside do go
and buy and be inspired and the story of
the rat stabbing is also in there
Thank You Jo